hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow episode 13 video
canary so this is mostly meant to be a
conclusion to what they're considering
this initial canary arc so we're moving
into the next arc of the show so I'll
try to explain what that is whenever
they announced that caity lotz was
coming back I know there was some
confusion as to how that was gonna
happen whether it was gonna be a
flashback what kind of story it was
gonna tell she was a relatively minor
present in the episode but it's always
fun to see her back so I really want
team arrow to do some more drugs so Marc
Guggenheim has an excuse to bring her
back
okay so careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five no more secrets I feel like I
should have known ahead of time if
Oliver was gonna be telling Thea his
secret then Laurel is pluggin end up
telling her dad about Sara was anyone
else surprised with Thea's reaction to
Oliver coming clean about his secret I
did I did like the reveal if you have
trouble reading a scene like what the
tone is supposed to be usually you can
tell from the type of music cue they use
and when the music swelled up with this
really positive sound you get you could
tell that they wanted it to be a
positive reaction they wanted it to be
like a good brother-sister moment if
Thea had been super pissed about it it
would he used a way more depressing
soundtrack here's an interesting thought
how many times have we gone down into
the arrow cave with the lights all
turned off that's what it looks like
when no one's in there Oliver isn't made
of money anymore so they got to turn the
lights off whenever they leave the room
so pretty much now everybody knows each
other secrets except Captain Lance still
doesn't know who the arrow is I mean he
probably knows but as far as the show is
telling us he does not know but I think
it's implied I think he has a pretty
good idea that Oliver's the arrow
this was the hurdle they all had to jump
over before they could team up and
prepare for Rachele goal so we have a
United team Merlyn team arrow front
versus Rey shall go in the League of
Assassins
even though Thea totally hates Merlin's
guts now number four the place where
Merlyn dares not to follow they buried
the lead a little bit just because we
were all so happy to see Chase go I'm so
happy that he's dead I hated that
character but his reaction to Merlyn
sounded suspiciously like a challenge
usually any time one character throws
something else in another character's
face like you don't deserve to be the
canary you're a fraud they need to
overcome that challenge to evolve as a
character so Merlyn is going to have to
quote-unquote
dare to follow if he's going to evolve
as a character you guys can let me know
if you agree but logically don't you
think that this is setting Merlyn
to sacrifice himself to save Thea she
totally hates him right now
wants nothing to do with them Merlyn is
like I understand that I totally get
that but we need to worry about the big
stuff now Rochelle Goyle we need to deal
with that
I feel like somewhere deep down inside
he really does care he really does want
Thea to love him and the only way to
jump over that hurdle is to make a
heroic sacrifice what's a bigger
sacrifice to make than your life and
more on the idea of challenges and
rewards Laurel had the big challenge in
this episode she had to face her doubts
so that she could believe that she was
capable of being the canary I mean she's
still not prepared she still has a lot
of training to do but internally she's
more self-assured she's not gonna keep
downing herself so much so she defeated
that challenge now she can continue
being the canary
what would Merlin's rewards be for
sacrificing his life well one would be
the love of his daughter Thea the other
could be resurrection it's really hard
to tell whether or not arrows gonna
renege on its superpowers its Lazarus
Pit like the more fantastical aspects of
the DC Universe but it's totally
possible that in like a finale
post-credit scene we could see some
Lazarus Pit action moving on to number 3
Amanda Waller is starting to look like a
bigger villain than ratio ghoul I'd
actually wondered after her season two
if Amanda Waller was gonna turn into one
of the big villains of season three I
don't know if that's gonna continue to
be the case we will get some more
suicide [ __ ] episodes so presumably
we'll learn more about Amanda Waller
maybe she'll get worse maybe she'll get
better but she came off so awful in this
episode she threatened to kill Thea
whether or not she truly meant it I I
kind of think she did if you're not a
comic book reader Amanda Waller in the
comics is stone-cold
she's almost considered an enemy of the
Justice League even though she works for
the US government she's like one of
those devil you know characters yeah
they might end up defeating China white
before the finale in the in the
flashbacks but will that make Amanda
Waller a good person no it will not we
also got some more information about
Masayo in the flashbacks he is really
good at deceiving people so think about
what that means for what's going on in
present-day with Miss a oh we had that
scene where he informed rachel gould
that they went back to Starling so does
that mean he is triple crossing Rachel
Ghul it gets a little confusing I don't
think it's quite that convoluted I think
he is trying to help Oliver at the end
of the day that's just my takeaway based
on the Masayo flashback scene where he
was like I knew that Amanda Waller would
catch you so I gave you
information on to number two Caity Lotz
returns she's so much fun I'm always
happy whenever she comes back to the
show
I don't know that she's gonna come back
before the end of the season that could
change they haven't really made
announcements about what's gonna be
happening in the last couple of episodes
it sounds like she's not but because
Laura is still feeling a lot of grief
and she's still starting on the path to
becoming a fully actualized black canary
she's probably gonna reference Sara a
lot in conversation it's just like the
way Felicity talks about Barry whenever
he's not around or the way team flash
talks about felicity whenever she's not
around thinking they can still reference
other characters without them appearing
on screen if she does come back in
future cameos I'm assuming they're gonna
drop the vertigo I mean they wouldn't do
that three seasons in a row people
aren't just gonna keep doing vertical
all the time so she's probably gonna
come back in flashbacks what I'd really
like to see is the story of how she got
started in the League of Assassins Nyssa
kind of explained what happened when she
first found Sara she was broken she took
her in but we really didn't get to see
that so it'd be really awesome to see a
side story like if we get a story about
Nyssa growing up in the League of
Assassins that'd be really awesome if
Sara could be a big part of that I just
I feel like League of Assassins is
untouched territory right now we just we
haven't seen a lot from inside the
league in the arrowverse and my number
one moment
team arrow has to conquer its fears in
order to conquer Rachel Ghul what Merlyn
meant at the end of the episode it was a
little bit different he meant he has to
conquer your fears to take away racial
goals advantage because Rachael who uses
your fears against you for Oliver and
Thea that means going to Leon you to
regain their killer edge for Laurel it
meant facing her self-doubt everyone on
Team arrow really has to do that
themselves obviously they couldn't do a
story for everyone so they just focused
on those characters and just to bring
Ray Palmer back into the story we're
gonna be seeing more Adam he's gonna
have to do that same thing too he'll
have to have that big call-to-action
health to face his fears
I think episode 15 will be the real
jumping off point for that Marc
Guggenheim said that basically like
episodes 14 through the finale are
basically gonna be a crescendo of
craziness the quote that he had is is
that Oliver dying in the mid-season
finale is gonna be the least crazy
WTF moment take that as you will he was
very vague but what could be crazier
than Oliver dying and coming back to
life so here's my big question for you
guys
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and when do you want caity lotz
to come back so the
a whole lot of Easter eggs in the
episode so I'll just talk about a couple
things that didn't really fit into my
top five one is Thea versus Chase I was
really hoping that that would turn into
a bigger fight scene I feel like we'll
get a big Thea battle but we're just not
we're not quite there yet she's kind of
on the same arc as Laurel like they've
been in training but they're not up to
like Oliver Roy level
Roy's been training way longer than any
of them and he's still not that great so
fingers crossed for a really big Thea
fight before the end of the season she's
really good with swords so it'll it
primed it being like a sword battle and
more on those lines Stephen Amell was
was playing around with a lightsaber
recently in a facebook video that he
posted I know he and Merlyn are gonna
train with swords soon I was kind of
hoping to get a teaser for that but but
I guess they had to set up this next
episode the Slade Wilson episode next
week I'm thinking of next week is like
arrow great outdoors edition bring your
camping gear it's gonna be a lot of fun
anybody who's ever gone camping and
taken their friend who doesn't like to
go camping will totally get that last
scene where Thea's like lagging behind
Oliver is like come on this will be
awesome you'll love it I didn't really
have any big thumbs down about the
episode but obviously I wasn't a big fan
of the chase character they totally took
care of that so I have to give him a
giant thumbs up for that I am gonna be
doing a Q&A video for this I'll try to
get that out tomorrow be sure to
subscribe to get it so all those videos
that I haven't done yet that everyone's
asking about don't worry those will
happen before the weekend so while you
guys wait for all that stuff to drop you
can click here to catch up on this
week's flash firestorm video and you can
click here to learn all about spider-man
joining the Marvel Universe so thank you
so much for watching happy Valentine's
Day for everyone who watches this video
tomorrow so let's high-five I'll see you
guys soon
you